[MUSIC PLAYING]
KARMEL ALLISON: Hi and
welcome to Coding TensorFlow.
I'm Karmel Allison, and
I'm here to guide you
through a scenario using
TensorFlow's high-level APIs.
This video is the second
in a three-part series.
In this, we'll dig deeper into
preparing the data for machine
learning, including
using feature
columns, categorical
data, and much more.
We'll also explore
a machine learning
model built using Keras that
can be trained with this data.
In the previous video, we
spoke about a complex data set
and how you can
load that and get
it ready to use in TensorFlow.
We used the Covertype data set
from the US Forestry Service
and Colorado State
University, which
has about 500,000 rows of
geophysical data collected
from particular regions
in National Forest areas.
We are going to use the
features in this data set
to try to predict the soil type
that was found in each region.
We took the raw data and put
it into a TensorFlow data
set that generates dictionaries
of feature tensors and labels,
but we still have
lots of feature types.
Some are continuous,
some are categorical,
some are one-hot encoded.
We need to represent
these in a way that
is meaningful to an ML model.
You'll learn how to
do that in this video,
so let's get started.
We are going to use
feature columns for that.
In TensorFlow, a feature column
is a configuration class.
It doesn't itself hold any
data but it tells our model
how to transform the raw data so
that it matches the expectation
in many ML models that the
data is numeric and continuous.
If you're working with data
that is already numeric,
image data, for example, feature
columns may not be necessary,
but for many real-world
applications,
data is structured
and represents
vocabularies or human
concepts that we
need to transform before we can
use them in machine learning
models.
Feature columns are a
great way to do that.
Let's take, for example, our
Covertype category, which
is an integer between
1 and 7 that represents
the type of tree in the region.
You'll note that
all we've done here
is define a type
of feature, and we
haven't passed any of our
data into that feature yet.
It is just a
configuration object
that will tell our
model to expect
categorical IDs less than
the outer range value of 8.
Now we have to
configure how we want
to transform our categorical
data for use in a model that
expects continuous data.
Using feature columns,
we can trivially
build a set of instructions
that allow the model to convert
the categories into an
embedding column, as shown here.
Now, we could have done this
processing in our data parsing
function ourselves,
converting the categorical IDs
to a one-hot vector manually.
The advantage of
using feature columns
is that the
transformations they encode
become part of the model's
graph and can therefore be
exported with the saved model.
So you should push
any transformations
that you want to apply to
data both during training
and at inference time
into feature columns.
We can define columns
for each of our features.
Data that is already
numeric is straightforward.
We just use a numeric column.
Sometimes, as in the case
of soil type data here,
data is spread
out over a vector,
and numeric feature columns
allow us to easily capture
that relationship with
the shape argument
so that our model understands
wilderness area as a length 40
tensor rather than 40
independent tensors.
All right, so we configure all
of our features, and then what?
Well, these become
the first layer
of our model using
a feature layer.
When we train our
model, this first layer
will act like any
other Keras layer,
but its primary role will be to
take in the raw data, including
the categorical indices,
and transform it
into the appropriate
representations
that our neural
net is expecting.
This layer will also handle
creating and training
our embedding Covertype.
So if you have data that
needs transformation
before it fits into a model--
maybe it's categorical
like ours or even has
string names and vocabularies--
you can use feature columns to
handle those transformations,
batch by batch, in
TensorFlow, rather
than having a whole separate
pipeline to do feature
transformations in memory.
TensorFlow provides many
feature columns and even ways
to combine individual
columns into more
complex representations of the
data that your model can learn.
So, before we wrap
up, let me quickly
show you how this would be a
layer in a Keras model, which
we'll go into in more
detail in the next video.
Note that we are
using tf.keras here,
which implements
the Keras API spec
but adds additional
TensorFlow-specific
features on top of
it, like support
for TensorFlow's eager
execution, optimizers,
and so on.
Since the first
thing I want to try
is a simple sequence of
deep learning layers,
Keras is the easiest
way to start.
We will start with a
simple sequential model,
but what I want
to focus on right
now is just this first layer.
Our first layer
is a feature layer
that will do all the data
transformation we just
discussed and feed
the transformed data
into the rest of the model.
We'll do that in part three
of this series, where we'll
look at adding the data and
training the model with it,
including choosing loss
functions and optimizers.
It will be right here on the
TensorFlow YouTube channel,
so don't forget to hit
that Subscribe button,
and I'll see you there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]